mom and dad for a lot of emphasis on  education they wanted us to study hard  which i think is quite common for  migrant families out of the three of us  is went straight into James roost high  school to selectively my parents thought  that they had struck gold  they had seen that other children who  had gone to selected high schools had  come out and become the leaders of the  world the lawyers the solicitors the the  engineers the politicians maybe these  are occupations that gives you good  incomes so to speak and also sort of  more status my brother then said I am  going to choose education I want to be a  teacher and the air was heavy then you  really could cut the air with a knife  you really could hear a pin drop they  said you know why why do you think we've  come to this country for what do you  think was the purpose of us leaving  behind all our families in our  pre-established life did you think we  came here for the web ha